[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nor is ever to think of a Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John we answer your questions
give you dubious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC Wimbledon how you do it John I am
doing all right I'm all right yeah you
know Hank as you may be aware I am a
semi-professional player of the video
game FIFA and the two star players on my
team AFC Wimbledon are named John Green
and John Green they're two people who
are married to each other they co-parent
to child named JJ and I just I just
received terrible terrible news that
ball John Green broke his ankle Oh God
and he's out for three months Oh for
three months no man ah and I just I
don't have a really deep squad because
you know it's AFC Wimbledon yeah we
don't have a ton of money and we can't
afford to lose a player like Paul John
Green so I'm furious with the Oxford
United player who made that horrible
tackle I'm furious with the referee for
not making it a red card tackle I'm just
I'm just annoyed but other than that I'm
doing well Howard no if it's in the game
John it's in the game I'm good I have a
sore throat and I'm worried that it's
gonna get worse I feel like I'm at the
stage where it's like oh I'm getting
sick aren't I what should I do to
prevent this from happening take all of
the pills that don't do anything quick
and so I do that and then I get sick
anyway because the pills don't actually
do anything but they should are marketed
so make us think that they do and also
we will do anything to prevent the
sickness so I'm having that moment and I
just I just took three very large pills
that smelled like the inside of a pipe
and now I've got my fingers crossed all
right sounds good you want a short poem
for the day tell me a short poem this
poem is from Richard Brown again several
people have asked me why I've never read
a Richard Brautigan poem he did write a
lot of short poems this one is called a
love poem it's so nice to wake up in the
morning all alone
and not have to tell somebody you love
them when you don't love them anymore by
Richard Brautigan that's my god a love
poem hey yeah Hank you know I just got
back from an amazing vacation with Sarah
we were in Jamaica for five days we had
an awesome time we loved going to
Jamaica and I am so incredibly lucky to
like my spouse it's such it's the
biggest thing in a human life I think
for me at least yeah Catherine and I you
will have if you watch the vlog brothers
you'll have seen this video already but
just last night we recorded a video
where we taste test Valentine's Day
candy together uh-huh and I was just
watching that video you know as I was
editing it and I was like boy do I like
her yeah that's something that Richard
Brautigan never really had in his life I
think it was married four times and
never particularly successfully and and
he died in his 40s so yeah we got we've
got we've gotten very lucky hey let's
answer some questions from our listeners
well first I want to start out with I
guess this is a question but it is in
regards to the last pod in which Andrea
asks specifically to John in this week's
pod last week's pod you informed Dalia
that you are really really not a liberal
but then you and Hank both go on to
States so many liberal positions that
you agree with so in what sense are you
a conservative is it like taxes or what
please explain and then Andrea has put a
pumpkin with the Linux penguin carved
into it as her sign-off Wow yes that's a
very that's a solid sign I'll sign off
yeah so Hank is a proper liberal right
wouldn't you say that Hank well I mean
I'm further left of you probably but I
would say you're essentially a communist
whereas I believe in markets I believe
that the reason refrigerators are
inexpensive today and why so many of us
are able to enjoy them is because
markets and competition and I really do
think that in many ways markets enrich
our lives
I think that they are part of why
poverty has gone down a lot in the last
hundred years and so I do believe that
markets can solve a lot of problems I
also think that there are places that
markets clearly fail especially health
care markets are terrible at dealing
with health care they are terrible at
dealing with crime they are terrible at
dealing with national defense there are
a bunch of things that markets aren't
good at but I do believe in them
probably more than than you do yeah I
have actually come around more -
especially since you know running
several businesses of my own there are
times that I'm like boy these government
regulations sure do keep small business
down and I'd like yeah I like there are
times that are that are like that but
there's also like what I find
extraordinarily frustrating more than
anything about running a small business
is knowing that I pay much higher
corporate taxes than Apple and Google do
and I just hate that like I find it
extraordinarily frustrating like why do
we subsidize these massive companies
while my company pays 40 percent
corporate tax and yeah I mean the other
thing about that is corporate taxes in
the US I agree are too high which is not
a liberal health liberal position
although actually President Obama felt
that corporate taxes in the u.s. were
too high I I think that the great thing
about small businesses is they create
more jobs per dollar of revenues and
large businesses do so Hank and I
privately have always said that we want
to ensure that no matter how big or
small our our Enterprise is that it
employs more people per dollar of
revenue than Pepsi does and we are we
are good on that front yep because small
businesses are just they're better at
employing people they're better I think
on average in terms of wages as well and
I do think that the too often the system
is a little bit biased against small
businesses yes and that is another place
where I probably fall a little
right-of-center that said there's a lot
of things that are politicized in our
current
political discourse that I just don't
think should be political issues like I
don't think that climate change is a
political issue I think maybe we can
have political disagreements about how
government can best contribute to
solving the problem of climate change
but I don't think whether climate change
is happening and is caused by humans is
a political topic I also think that you
know for a long time we didn't
politicize refugee resettlement and we
didn't politicize foreign aid and now we
do and III don't think that those are
particularly political issues I think I
think there's a weird left-right divide
that doesn't need to exist on those
issues so there's a lot of issues where
I just feel like you know Hank and I
both maybe just don't fall just don't
don't see these things as political the
way that they're politicized in our
current discourse
yes it's very frustrating to watch
something that go from being like very
few people know about this at all the
people who know about it realize that
it's quite good and or that it needs to
be dealt with or whatever it is and then
suddenly like somebody finds it and it's
like ah I can score points with this one
let's quick turn it into an issue right
I on either side either they're like
saying like I want to turn this into an
issue like I'm the champion and defender
of this or saying like I have found this
issue and I I want to tell the world
about what a terrible thing it is yeah
yeah in general I mean and then it score
it scores the points and then and then
the entire topic becomes like just
another thing on the long list of things
that that like you're supposed to like
sign up for one side or the other yeah I
think that's a lot of my frustration
right now is just that we aren't a lot
of times I feel like we're not taking
these issues particularly seriously like
they're being treated as opportunities
to score points rather than as places
where we need to have difficult
discussions health care is probably the
biggest example of that in the United
States right now where you know nobody's
being very serious about the health care
conversation because the truth is it's
extremely complicated and it involves
big big trade-offs and we're going to
have to make
this trade offer that trade off and
we've got to talk about it that way
instead of pretending that there's some
easy solution that won't result in pain
for anybody well I got another question
John this one is from amber and it's
also for you so I think I feel like
sometimes I only read the questions that
are for me but I want to give you one
John amber says hello brothers my
favorite author is Charles Bukowski I
unashamedly loved his dark humor and
honest writing style and yet when my
friends read his books because I've told
them how much I like them they come back
and assume more about my personality and
opinions because of my affinity towards
him am i a bad person for reading books
written by a bad person should I find a
new favorite author should d-h Lawrence
take the number one place to compensate
to my embarrassment dubious advice is
welcomed with open arms sent as to be
received lovingly amber UK oh this is a
tough one Hank I mean there's two
questions inside of this question one is
you know can you separate the artist
from the work is it possible to love
something beautiful written by a deeply
flawed or broken person and I think the
answer to that is yes although it's
complicated and I no longer labor under
the delusion that I used to that we can
completely separate the author from
their work that however does not really
apply to Charles Bukowski because his
writing is very sexist and racist just
as he himself was as a person so it's
this is I think a somewhat different
question you know I I read Charles
Bukowski when I was in high school and I
really liked facets of his work it felt
like honest and raw to me in a way that
most other fiction and poetry didn't
feel you know it had that that beat poet
vibe but even more down on its luck and
something about that really resonated
with me so I I definitely get what
you're saying amber I I do think you
know looking back now
at Bukowski x' work that it is deeply
racist and misogynistic and that is
destructive to the social order so I
think that your friends concerns are
legitimate and I think this is a tough
question I think it's really really hard
to navigate this but I think if you can
understand why people are hurt by it or
feel that it is cruel to them or feel
like it's cruel to people who are
vulnerable then III think that may go a
long way toward us waging some of the
fears and concerns that you have and
that your friend says I yeah I have to
say that I am no good at this question
cuz I know nothing about Charles
Bukowski I also wasn't very good at it
Hank but listen if people who want good
advice they go to other podcasts I I I
do think that there's like like like
reading things it's so hard for me to
read something that is opinionated and
appealing without sort of somewhat
incorporating the opinion and being like
I do kind of get where you're coming
from mm-hmm and so that's that's a hard
thing for me where it's like like like
my brain just can't deal with the fact
that like I disagree with the
perspective but I really like the
writing mm-hmm and and so like I start
to get swayed over and and I think that
that's the the sort of dangerous thing
I completely agree I think that's a
great point do you want to ask me a
science question John since I asked you
a literature question sure I want to ask
you a science question Hank this is
something of a social science question
though it comes from Christina who
writes dear John and Hank I'm from
Finland and I have a question related to
your new president I'm angry that I need
to pay attention to what the president
of the United States is doing this says
it a science it is a science question
it's a history question he's not my
president and I feel like I shouldn't
have to care about what he does however
his policies
wide international impact and it seems
like he's effing up the entire planet
I'm actually worried about him starting
the next world war or him not stopping
Russia from starting it I don't know why
you'd be worried about that in Finland
and if the problem is not going to be
world war then maybe it's his climate
change policies and his delusional
opposition to science in general it
seems pretty bad why does any country
have this much power over the rest of
the world I think it's unfair is it
unreasonable of me to think so our Prime
Minister is a complete idiot but at
least he can only ruin his own country
not anyone elses we're still alive when
your next podcast is supposed to air
Christina oh man there's a lot to go
over here first of all the part where
John said it is a science question it's
history yes everything the history of
man is everything a science everything a
science first of all I mean I feel like
there's a big difference between what
has been done and what we're afraid will
be done and getting those two things
locked together as if they are one thing
like yes we need to be concerned about
what may be done and this person does
not seem to me to be the best maker of
decisions but there is a difference
between what has been done and what we
are afraid might be done and it seems
like you have lumped those into one
thing as if the things that we are
afraid that are going to happen have
already happened and that's a really
scary way of looking at the world right
the risk of catastrophizing is that it
also deflects attention away from what's
actually happening I think we have a
strong independent judiciary in the
United States I think we separation of
powers still function in our government
I don't think that a world war is
necessarily on the horizon but I do
think that there are lots of legitimate
concerns about what's happening right
now and we need to be serious about them
that said III think that if you live in
Finland your your life on average is
pretty good except for the weather and I
think that in eight years or four years
or two years or maybe even just like six
months your life will on average still
be pretty good
yeah and so I would I would try to take
some solace in that but it is difficult
to have your life deeply affected by
politicians who you did not choose
however that is a much bigger problem
for I think like people living in
refugee camps in Kenya right now than it
is for the vast majority of us and so
it's a I want to focus on the people who
are who are being directly affected by
by the current policies yeah there's a
it's a strange thing though that that
America is so powerful that the the
people who vote in America have impacts
on pretty much everybody and that is a
reason why we have to vote carefully and
also vote but I am happy to be an
American citizen because that is not the
case for me at least I get to vote in
the elections that affect the whole
world but I will say that I would rather
it be America than some other really
powerful countries I don't know if
that's just me like being biased but if
we're gonna have no yeah you if it's
gonna be us or Putin
I prefer US yeah margin wait there's one
other thing I wanted to say here Hank
which is there's this great quote from
the theologian Miroslav Volf that I
think about in this context and that my
therapist shared with me recently
politics touches everything but politics
isn't everything not by a long shot
I like it John I'm gonna ask this
question that you've got highlighted
right now because I figured that means
you want me to ask it it's from Amelia
who asks dear Hank and John I live in
Toronto I've noticed that on major
streets Oh God Amelia please take us in
just can we please come and visit can
you just is there possible that we could
just what can you get me off of the list
that says that I'm not welcome in Canada
please Amelia please do you work for
Justin Trudeau can you talk to someone
I'm sorry what is the question the
street lights alternate sides on major
streets while on residential streets
they're all on the same side the thing
is on my street the street lights are on
the south side until mid block and then
they switch sides now
they're on the north side this is
madness can you help me shed some light
smiley face on this issue who decides
these things is there any regularity at
all in street light placing is a
different where you guys live
I and then Amelia says memento mori as a
sign off that's my favorites I know if
we've ever had in the history of dear
Hank and John I'm signing off all of my
emails memento mori from now on you know
what that means right I just googled it
it means remember that you have to die
that's right I mean why would you ever
sign off an email best wishes ever again
when you can just memento mori' it and
put the email recipient right in the
place where they need to be anyway Hank
why do streetlights change places I only
wanted to read this question because of
the sign off I almost missed it there
are places John where a train going
across a national border will have to be
removed from the train tracks have new
reels put on it and then put back on to
the differently gauged train tracks that
are different width apart because one
country started their train tracks and
the other country started their train
tracks and they're like oh we have to
bring them together but then they're
like oh we've got all these train tracks
that are different sizes in our
countries there's only one solution and
it's to change the wheels on all the
trains what does that have to do with
streetlights street lights are not that
big of a deal
I'm just not super concerned about the
street just not answering that question
there one person like they were doing
this street lights on one side of the
street and like they were coming down
and they were like oh but back there
when we started the street lights like
50 miles away on that side of the of the
town we did it on the other street and
then like it met halfway in the middle
of the block here and Amelia's block I'm
not super concerned about that it's a
thing that happened but it's not that I
just I'm not I'm not concerned I do uh
in my residential neighborhood there's
one streetlight per block on the
intersection and no on the street at all
that's a very long so that's how it is
for being
should for an answer that is basically I
don't know but yeah we we don't know
Amelia no it's not I don't know it's
DeSean John John it's not I don't know
it's I don't care okay we don't know and
we don't care Amelia but memento mori
alright Hank I've got another question
this one comes from Sarah who writes
Dear John and Hank I'm a Girl Scout in
the midst of cookie season oh man oh man
that's my favorite time of year and a
controversial one at that why is this a
controversial cookie season oh no II
don't even know the controversy it's
possible that we're waiting deeply into
something that we don't understand but
we're just gonna do what we usually do
and move forward in ignorance I'm trying
to sell Girl Scout cookies is the point
I've run across several problems such as
a foot of snow and the fact that people
are less likely to buy cookies from a
teenager than a cute little kid
my initial idea was to send you guys the
link to my cookie website so you could
share it in exchange for a shipment of
478 boxes of cookies delivered to John
or Hanks office mmm I mean if you've got
to choose Sarah she was mine I told this
idea of my parents and they responded
that they weren't interested in
investing two thousand three hundred
ninety dollars plus shipping to secure a
sponsorship deal
ah which is disappointing in hindsight I
probably should have done the math
beforehand so instead of offering
cookies I asked if you could share the
link to my cookie website and instead of
promoting the cookies promote the
donation of cookies the boxes of cookies
donated would go to a local food pantry
while cookies are not necessarily
nutritious they are a rare treat to
people who depend on food from these
types of places my website is all right
everybody get ready to write this down
if you're in your car don't do get your
pencil ready pull over
open up the Notes app on your phone
Digital cookie girl Scout's dot org
slash scout slash Sarah seven five five
zero three five they made that easy
how could I forget that URL it's
basically google.com note cookie sales
and March 12th and the link will become
inactive after that so I think this
a lovely idea Hank let us let us go buy
some Girl Scout cookies and ship them to
food pantries around the country I think
that's a lovely idea let's do it let's
do it John I think we're ready to move
on to the next question I just had for
the first time in my life a nerd rope
and what a nerd rope is what a nerd rope
is is this basically like you know like
how there are those Twizzlers that
aren't Twizzlers and you can like pull
out a string from the other oh my god
made of nerds it would nerd flavoring
yeah no and then they dip that into
something sticky and then they'd roll
that around in a bunch of nerds oh my
god
oh my god and I'm like can I get four
hundred seventy eight of us oh my god
without a sponsor that sounds really
amazing Wow I bet it's an excellent
source of vitamin C as well you know on
the back of the packaging it said a
thoughtful portion is one-half a rope
and I was like well thank you for
letting me know
nerd rope I have come to you for
thoughtful portioning that's why I
bought this thing that's made of only
sugar I mean my reaction to that would
just be like you know what you know what
I didn't ask I didn't ask what a
thoughtful portion would be all right so
don't don't go interjecting your
thoughts about what constitutes a
thoughtful portion of nerd rope I'm
gonna have you know you know when I'm
done eating this nerd rope when my
stomach hurts yeah it's like when
Netflix is like are you still watching
Jane the virgin and I'm like yes yes I
am still watching Jane the virgin
Netflix why are you trying to shave me
it's a good show yeah yeah like all I'm
doing is using your service sorry I
don't know why I started cursing so much
in the last five minutes I've got there
are two really good science questions
here that you are refusing to read so
I'm going to read one of them I read you
a literature question John yeah that's
not really a literature question that
was more of a minefield that you're
asking me to navigate anyway what's your
science question alright this one's from
Jamie who asks dearest misters Green
our bugs as susceptible to microwaves as
humans are I was microwaving some
instant noodles and after the four long
minutes it took to sufficiently cook
them I went to take the noodles out and
noticed a small gnat like creature still
alive and crawling in the microwave I
know that the messy cage on the inside
protects humans outside from the
microwaves but this little bug had no
such protection that I just give that
bug radiation poisoning feeling
incredibly guilty until proven innocent
Jaime I've welcomed people sign-offs are
getting really good before you answer
this question I just want to tell you
what I think probably happened and then
you can tell me if I'm right I think
that when Jaime hit start on the
microwave there was no living thing in
the microwave but then the radiation
caused a living thing to come into
existence out of the noodles no all
right well I was well I did my best I
did my best that was my best guest that
like doesn't doesn't radiation caused by
like evolution or something
I saw the fly I saw the movie the fly
that's what I'm basing this there was a
Hardy a fly in there with Jeff Goldblum
John it's been a while since I saw it to
be perfectly honest so first I have good
news for you Jaime probably you did you
very very small chance well you
definitely didn't give the bug radiation
poisoning radiation poisoning is caused
by a different type of radiation that
comes out of a microwave if the bug
survived there's a good chance that the
bugs gonna be fine you could have killed
that bug but you didn't and I have to
say I did a little bit of research I'm
not sure and neither is anyone else and
this is a known phenomenon that like an
ant in a microwave will not get killed
they think maybe it's because the the
wavelength of microwaves is is large
enough that it doesn't really interact
with like if you had a big box of ants
they would get hot but one ant doesn't
get hot but there's also the possibility
that there are areas inside of the
microwave that don't really get hit with
microwaves as much which is why there's
a a it's sort of like a field inside of
the thing and there are hot areas and
cold areas of like microwave
concentration which is why the like the
little turntable spins to get your food
to like hit all of the good good good
areas of the microwave and maybe then
that was just hanging out and like a
pocket that didn't have so much
microwave radiation but but the good
news is you should feel innocent because
you accidentally almost killed a gnat
but you didn't than that was fine and
we'll be fine and in the future check to
make sure that there's no fruit flies
hanging out inside of your microwave I
mean I would argue that the microwave
failed to do its job which was to
sanitize the situation right like what
I'm really asking a microwave to do
ultimately is not to heat my food I'm
asking it to make my food clean and
you've really upset something that's
fundamental to my understanding of the
universe just now
which is that microwaves make my food
not poisonous so let's just move on well
if you if you microwave it long enough
that will happen just because of the
food will get hot and the hot will kit
like if the if the ant was inside your
burrito and then the ant would die
because it gives super hot in the
burrito and then death ant but the ants
hanging out where there's less stop like
it's it's really like it's remarkable
that this is a known phenomenon that we
do not have the answer to I love that
there's seems like there's a lot of
known phenomenon we don't have the
answer to there's so much science out
there that we could get to the bottom of
and we just need people who are curious
you know like Jamie may be doing a
little bit of science so maybe maybe
what you should do is put up like start
doing some tests get a bunch of ants
whatever put them in your microwave see
what happens don't do don't do that
that's terrible advice let's move on to
another question Nick this question is
from Ken who writes Dear John and Hank I
turned 70 this year and I've written and
fought in March for human rights civil
rights
water and clean air for more than 50
years and what I saw it looked so close
and now it's just crumbling around me I
need some dubious advice how do I get
out of bed gird up my loins and take up
the fight again when it's obvious that
so many people don't share my views and
will never ever do so no matter how
convincing my arguments are I await your
dubious advice Ken here's my advice I
don't know what Hank is gonna say but my
advice is that the arc of history is
very long and if you look at where the
world was 70 years ago when you were
born more people have more rights fewer
people live in poverty human lives are
longer and healthier and more productive
and better educated than they were 20
years ago or 50 years ago and that is
partly due to your activism and so it
has not been for naught and it still
isn't yeah Ken thank you first of all
and and I'm looking forward to fighting
for clean water and clean air for you
know the next 50 years as well though
I'm probably not gonna make it that long
am i it's okay I like your odds for 50
years okay all right
Wow how old are you 36 mmm I don't think
you're 36 buddy I'll be are you God I'm
so old yeah thanks I like your odds for
50 years I don't love my odds for 50
years but that does remind me Hank that
today's podcast is brought to you by
memento mori memento mori you're gonna
die and today's podcast is also brought
to you by the Jeff Goldblum movie the
fly John hasn't seen it in a while but
he's pretty sure he knows some stuff
about microwaves now and of course
today's podcast is brought to you by the
nation of Finland the nation of Finland
deliciously close to Russia and this
podcast is brought to you by those
trains where they have to stop the train
at the border of countries and take the
train off the tracks and put new wheels
on the train so it could fit on the
train tracks from the other country
those train tracks
that's a good one Hank I was really I
was solid that's gonna go down in
history is one of the best hey quit
answer one more question before I give
any I know I had I had something else I
wanted to say to Cale you didn't get
finished by my thing to get right into
sponsorships and I just wanted to say
that we are all going to be fighting for
things that we will never see and that
is how like to me being a human isn't
about like getting to a place that like
when I die I can feel good about where
we ended up Humanity is about always
making progress forever and so knowing
that the work is never going to be done
but it's gonna be better if you take the
average over a long period of time and I
think that that is the case and I think
that we are gonna have to keep working
toward that goal and the and if you're
gonna accomplish your biggest goals
before you die then your biggest goals
aren't big enough I love that Hank I
also want to end on a note of optimism
or hope or at least to define maybe what
optimism looks like for us Hank with
this Star Trek question from Francis who
writes Dear John and Hank in Star Trek
and other utopian science fiction
content to the idea that the earth
unifies into one country is a popular
one and it's sort of the endgame for our
society this seems shocking to me
clearly there will never be a time when
every person agrees on most ideas we've
seen what happens when countries with
different beliefs and values are forced
together and this seems like the only
way a truly unified country of the earth
would happen in my opinion the end game
would be lots of small countries all
unified in a simpler way like the United
Nations my question is what do you think
the endgame is in terms of countries
will we one day be a perfectly unified
planet a critical space nerd Frances
I don't know man well in Star Trek it's
worth noting that the only reason we
have a unified planet is because we
don't have a unified galaxy yeah so like
you got the got people you're worried
about and you're like okay we need to
consolidate and be like okay well but to
be clear there's like in Star Trek it's
not just the unified planet it's the
United Federation of Planets so there
are there are planets in planets all
with their own you know like but yes
they do have common enemies and they
will fight together against those common
enemies and and that is kind of the
thing like you know there there have
been lots of times when like disparate
groups banded together because they were
faced by some outside threat and that's
sort of like the story but that's not
the only story of why people have come
together in larger and larger groups
like I think maybe what what Francis
isn't considering is that for most of
human history the largest group of
humans was like a hundred or 200 people
and and then in the last ten thousand
years our groups have gotten
progressively bigger and bigger and
bigger where now we have groups that are
1.4 billion people or 1 billion people
that all identify as part of the same
country to me there's no reason why we
can't have one group that identifies as
human instead of now there's no reason
why that that trend can't continue
except for maybe the lack of a common
enemy being something to hold us
together but I don't think that's the
only thing that holds cultures and
groups together so I do think it's
possible that we could have one big
human group in the future I also I also
think it's possible I think that the
like there are a couple of unifying
forces one is that there are better ways
to live that are objectively better and
we've seen that and that was part of you
know the end of the Cold War was you
know just how much better things got in
the you
and again John and I are gonna show a
little bit of our more conservative
stripe here because capitalism was
working so well in the US and and
communism was not working particularly
well and Russia now you can argue that
that was not because of communism it was
because of corruption but but like the
nice thing about capitalism is it sort
of like has its own systems built into
it that prevent certain kinds of
corruption certainly not all corruption
really certainly not all garage not not
truly well maybe not corruption then but
but things I don't know John I don't
know either but I think you're right in
general that human lives have improved
faster since 1990 that at any point in
all of human history so something's
working yeah and and I I think that
there are but there are better systems
and those that when the systems work
they can like the appeal of that like
the objective appeal of that is like it
exists despite the fact that there are
going to be lots of different reasons
why we also want to be more insular and
like hang out with people who are more
like us but at the same time I don't
think that that means that like a
unified humanity would not have
diversity it would have diversity of
ideas and types of people and different
systems and different economic systems
even the way that you know in a very
small town like Missoula there are
different economic systems and people
you know interface with the economy in
different ways on very small scales and
also on global scales so I I think that
perfectly unified is a weird weird
phrase and I don't know that it
accurately reflects like like the actual
goal of utopia but I do think that a
kind of utopia is possible and I don't
want to lose that dream I feel like we
kind of have as a species you know it
was there for a while in the 70s and 60s
and and a little bit in the 80s and then
it just you know and now now we're sort
of like a little cynical a little jaded
as a you know as
a culture in the culture that I
interface with and I I do want to keep
the dream of utopia alive and and I
think that there are utopias out there
we just have to try and find them and
the best ways we know how yeah I mean
I'm a very pessimistic person in general
but I actually believe that the biggest
problems that we face are solvable like
III think that absolute poverty for
instance is not inherent to human beings
and I think we may there are people
listening to this podcast who I hope and
believe will see a world within their
lifetimes that where absolute poverty is
treated as abnormal and where it you
know under five child mortality is below
one percent in every country in the
world and that's not going to be easy to
achieve but it's possible and I also
believe that we can see a dramatic
reduction in the number of conflict
deaths I think we've already seen that
in in the last 50 years and so I I am
hopeful about humanity's ability to
accomplish things together because I
think we've shown an ability to
accomplish things together speaking of
things that we've accomplished together
Hank of course the greatest the greatest
achievement in the history of our
species was the Reformation and then
five promotions and nine years of AFC
Wimbledon the greatest fan an
institution on earth and I think it's
time to move on to the news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon even though we have so
many good questions that I still want to
answer but we're out of time
so I want to thank the news from AFC
Wimbledon I I have to say something
which is that we received an email from
Victoria and she wrote Dear John and
Hank I'm a big fan of the podcast and I
listen keenly every week however as a
citizen at the UK there is something
that I just cannot stand anymore I'm
somewhat paraphrasing this email as said
in the news from AFC Wimbledon in
episode 79 they were supposed to play
Gillingham which John said was like jiff
in that there was no known way to
pronounce it correctly this is wrong
it is pronounced Gillingham soft G like
JM and that's important because
Gillingham hard G like girl is a
different town it isn't our Gillingham
is in Dorset
whereas Gillingham the football team is
from Kent both of which sound like
made-up regions of England that you can
only access by a magic but yeah so it's
very important apparently to pronounce
Gillingham correctly lest people think
that I am referring to a different town
spelled the exact same way but
pronounced differently yeah you will
recall that AFC Wimbledon after a
scoreless draw January 21st against
Chesterfield had two consecutive games
that were postponed thanks to one of the
greatest institutions in football league
1 which is of course frozen pitch and or
waterlogged however eventually things
had to dry out and they did just in time
for AFC Wimbledon to play Sheffield
United ha and perhaps we should have
stuck with waterlogged pitch because we
lost for nil and I have to say that
score line from everything I read rather
flatters AFC Wimbledon it could have
been much worse
so Sheffield United is overwhelmingly
the best team in Ligue 1 this year
they're definitely going to get promoted
or almost definitely they're very very
good and we are not at the moment very
very good we're down to 15th
after 28 games only 9 points clear of
the drop so that's where things stand at
the moment all right that was bad news
rosianna has just texted me to tell me
that there is a third Gillingham with a
this one is also with a hard G it's in
Norfolk there are three places in
England named Gillingham I mean it Hank
correct me if I'm wrong here
I've I haven't been to England that
often but isn't it a country that's like
eight square miles big
it doesn't seem super huge to me how do
you have three Zhi Ling hams in 8 miles
that they it's just a it's very dense
it's a dense country John we're used to
America where you can like walk for days
and never see a human being
Hank the population of England is 53
million people that's about the same as
the population of Indiana that is not
true at all and by about the same I mean
within one order of magnitude yeah what
is the population of Indiana John six
point five million people six point six
thank you yeah
it's a it's a dense it's a dense place
there's lots and there's lots of little
towns they're just close by by my
standards we're the little towns you
know you need to get in your car with
like some granola bars and make sure
your gas tanks full I have news from
Mars John if you are all interested in
that I know you weren't but I'm gonna
tell you what anyway tell me I'm excited
so Mars we have discovered through the
great work of the Curiosity rover was a
very wet place for a long time and it
was wet with water wetness and that
means that it was a warm place because
water is only around when it is above 32
degrees Fahrenheit or zero degrees
Celsius the question then becomes why
how did that happen it's farther away
from the Sun than we are here on earth
how was there so much water for so long
on the surface of this planet the
obvious answer is that it's like Venus
or even like Earth where it's being
heated up by a blanket of carbon dioxide
so you've got carbon dioxide the the
solar energy comes in it has a harder
time coming out and then you know the
whole planet gets warmer but based on
curiosity's analysis of rocks around
these wet areas there are not there's no
evidence that there was carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere at these times they're
like they were expecting to find certain
chemicals carbonates that would be the
would have like ended up in the soil and
they're just not there which makes them
feel like maybe there wasn't a lot of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere which
leaves like a huge question like what
how this isn't like water that existed
for a little while like it was you know
part of like a volcanic eruption or
something it was like for a long long
time potentially hundreds of millions of
years they're thinking maybe other
greenhouse gases like sulfur dioxide or
methane or nitrous oxide which are also
really strong greenhouse gases but those
greenhouse gases are reactive and and
they probably wouldn't hang out that
long unless there was some new input of
them all the time so basically we have
found that like with you know all this
data from curiosity we have this very
strong indication that there was a lot
of liquid water for a long time but not
a lot of carbon dioxide which means it's
just like.how why could there have been
liquid water all over the surface of
this planet and and a warm planet for so
long without any of the atmospheric
systems that we come to know as the
reasons why planets stay warm that's a
big big question and and hopefully as
curiosity and other missions continue to
gather data we could have a better idea
of why that's happening because it is
suddenly a huge mystery in Mars planet
science so Hank if it was something
other than carbon dioxide does that also
maybe mean that life would if it
developed would have developed very
differently because it would have had
different gases in the atmosphere or not
necessarily yes it does mean that it
also means potentially like if it is
methane that that methane could have
been produced by the life and so the
life was itself keep warm that's a that
is like a way out there theory by the
way just to be clear but yeah if also if
it was sulfur dioxide sulfur dioxide is
a very reactive chemical that that
things can metabolize so that could
totally be a different way for life to
work and to exist Wow
so the idea is
that the atmosphere would be would need
the life rather than the life needing
the atmosphere or I guess both well it
would be both ways yeah that's and
that's also like that's that that's the
case here on earth like obviously we
like humans could not exist if there
were not plants because there would be
no oxygen because oxygen is super
reactive and it would go away really
fast if it wasn't constantly being
produced mmm well we're doing our best
tank to find out what life would look
like without plants we're trying
I wanted to ask you one more question
just because I do I do find that really
really interesting and weird and
exciting I know that cows produce a lot
of methane is there a chance that there
were ancient cows on well interestingly
John the cows don't produce the methane
the bacteria in their guts do badness so
it would have been bacteria in the cow
guts
what if cows only exists because
bacteria from Mars came to earth and
then eventually colonized the guts of
cows possible yeah sure I'm into it sure
I like that idea
you know Hank I've done quite a bit of
research on what would happen if
different animals were completely
sterilized of all the bacteria that
colonized them because it's of great
interest to me personally and
professionally and humans would probably
survive although in in an extremely
damaged way cows however would die
definitely yep they are hugely dependent
upon their gut microbes whereas we are
only very dependent on our gut microbes
yes in fact like when babies are born
they don't have gut microbes and they
survive for a little while before they
start getting colonized so it's possible
but yes you would definitely be messed
up and and have a shortened life yes and
on that note Hank what did we learn
today Oh God everything and nothing
everything in nothing we learned that
John would like to talk to a Canadian
just any Canadian about whether or not
they know their prime minister Justin
girl Justin maybe they'd be interested
in having
really quite quite successful author and
podcaster to join the ranks or just get
me off of the list that doesn't let me
into the country without going into a
very unpleasant and scary interview
process every single time I understand
that I'm extremely lucky and I know
justin is probably listening to this
because I know he's a huge fan of the
pod Hank um and it's it's a taxing job
being the Prime Minister of Canada but
it's not that taxing it's only a nation
of 30 million people but 30 million and
one if I have anything to say about it
John God we really didn't answer for him
any questions we learned that we we
learned that Hank does not care why
streetlights are on alternate sides of
the street and we also learned that
someone once considered sending us
twenty four hundred dollars of Girl
Scout cookies and then didn't do it and
lastly and most importantly Hank we
learned
memento mori memento mori John thanks
for potting with me Hank thanks
everybody for listening you can email us
your questions at Hank and John at
gmail.com you can also follow us on
Twitter where I'm John Green and Hank is
Hank green yeah if you want to use the
the hashtag dear Hank and John over at
Twitter we'll see your questions as well
our podcast is produced by rosianna
halse rojas and sheridan Gibson our
editor is Nicholas Jenkins Victoria bon
giorno is our head of community and
communications and our music is by the
great gunnarolla thanks to everybody for
listening and everybody who helps out
with the podcast and also everybody who
supports us on patreon where you can
find our podcast patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John thanks again for listening
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
you
[Music]